hey everyone and welcome to a new series
where I challenge your knowledge of Dark
Souls 2 if you've been subscribed to my
channel for a while then you should
already know some of these awesome
changes to the game or maybe you'll at
least learn some new ones as usual let's
play the game with the like and the
dislike button if you learn something
new in this video leave a like if you
get 5 out of 5 and know everything well
done and feel free to leave a dislike
don't feel guilty I can take it alright
let's do it
number one I'll start us off with
something you might have already learned
from my videos with Dark Souls 2 comes
the addition of the death penalty 10% of
your maximum health will now deplete
upon every death and you can be brought
down to 50% maximum health before your
health stops depleting upon death this
is pretty damn brutal it reflects the
process of hollowing much more
realistically as your character
gradually becomes more hollow and loses
more and more sanity with every death as
you continue to die your face and body
become more and more decayed withered
and hollow you can restore your maximum
health by consuming a human effigy which
restores your humanity and it might
sound a bit masochistic for me to say it
but I actually really like this mechanic
it kind of reminds me of demon souls
where you lost 50% of your health upon
death except in Dark Souls 2 this will
gradually punish you for making mistakes
instead it's a bit more forgiving and it
ties in with the story really well as
hollowing is more of a gradual thing
number two you can now aim in first
person with catalysts just press l1 when
to handing the weapon additionally you
can cast a slower more powerful version
of the spell by pressing r2 instead of
r1 and these changes are great they give
more variety to sorcery spells can
finally be used in way more situations
making a pure sorcerer build much more
viable spells still use charges but
there are now consumable items that
restore those charges so you know what
all this means it means we can finally
play sorcerers properly in dark side
to number three so do you remember
getting killed on your first playthrough
by some guy who finished the game and
cut all the good equipment just so he
could kill you with it
so do I those were good times but now
some of the stronger armors actually
have stat requirements now this is a
great change since it will do a lot to
reduced winking you'll remember in Dark
Souls that people would be so level one
with decent armor sets and while armor
doesn't make a huge difference in the
grand scheme of things I think at least
it indicates that from software have
ganking in mind when they work on game
balance number four is a really cool
change
there were always lots of stories of
people who put their controller down and
then press the bumpers accidentally and
hidden NBC in front of them killing them
or a growing them but in Dark Souls 2
when you kill an NBC a gravestone will
appear in their place you can then
revive the NPC temporarily for a fairly
extreme price allowing you to browse
their wares and talk to them again so
this is a bit more forgiving but it
still punishes you for doing something
stupid I just wonder do you think they
know that they're dead because I
probably wouldn't want to sell my items
to the person who just killed me anyway
number 5 you can now get damaged or
poised broken during any animation
you're no longer invincible when
performing a riposte backstabbing
pulling a lever opening a door or going
through a fog gate
on the same note you can also cancel the
animation by pressing the button again
which I remember my friend tried to go
through the fog gate to fight the mirror
night and he just kept spamming the X
button to go through the fog gate and
essentially what it was doing was
pressing X and then cancelling it and
going through and cancelling and going
through until the enemies just came up
behind him and completely destroyed him
but yeah so in Dark Souls 2 this is
going to be a thing
it means backstabs are going to be less
of an option when fighting enemies in
groups and also running past can be
difficult now since developers could
just bottleneck you by putting a door in
your way meaning you could get attacked
while you open that door we're in Dark
Souls you're invincible when you open
that door and that's it overall these
are some really cool changes let me know
what you think they make me really
excited for the game
let me know how many you got out of five
as well and feel free to subscribe if
you want to be prepared for the next
episode in this series cheers guys
I'll catch you next time Dark Souls 2 is
shaping up to be a much more difficult
game than its predecessor
welcome again guys to Souls news an
embargo has just lifted on some more
details about Dark Souls 2 and these
these are probably the best facts we've
heard for a while so sit back relax and
let me share them with you if you want
to skip ahead to something more
interesting
check the description the three biggest
pieces of news are as follows one summon
phantoms now have a temporary lifespan -
every time you died